learn how to use terraform with azure in
this course from derrick morgan
derek is an excellent teacher and he has
created many popular courses
hello and welcome to the build a
development environment with terraform
and azure resume foundations project
course
now you might be wondering what exactly
a resume foundations project is
well a resume foundations project is a
project built to help you learn the
fundamentals of a technology to create
your own projects that you can use on
your resume
so let's take a look at what we're going
to build in this course
in this two hour project centered around
terraform you're going to use vs code
and deploy an as your linux machine
along with virtual network subnet
security groups etc that will serve as a
remote development environment that you
can log into directly from vs code
we'll utilize several terraform tools
and functions such as terraform state
format replace console variables
conditionals and more we'll also use
azure custom data and a provisioner to
bootstrap the virtual machine with
docker and add its connection
information to your vs code ssh
configuration file allowing you to
modify it for your own projects
since we'll make heavy use of
documentation and highlight the process
behind developing a brand new terraform
deployment you'll have the skills you
need to dive deeper into terraform and
add this extremely in demand skill to
your resume so what are you waiting for
go ahead enroll in the course let's
start building so that you can terraform
apply yourself
we're going to open a new project in vs
code install the azure cli connect to
our azure account and install a
terraform extension
so
let's get started first things first
what we want to do is we want to install
the azure cli this is going to allow
terraform to authenticate and access the
azure api so let's go ahead and knock
that out
now i am on a windows computer
and if we head over here to this link
which is provided in the resources
you'll see we have installation
instructions for windows mac os and
linux so go ahead and choose the
operating system you're using and go
ahead and install
now i'm going to be installing on
windows and i'll go ahead and show that
process it's not too complicated for
windows we just need to download this
file and run it so i'm going to do that
all right and i'm going to run that file
now
all right all set of course if you're
not done go ahead and pause the video
while your installer finishes up i'm
going to go ahead and click finish
and now since i already have vs code
open i'm just going to close it and
reopen it all right vs code has been
restarted i'm going to go ahead and open
a
terminal
all right so now what i'm going to do
is just run az login to get logged into
my account
now for you you can choose a browser to
open and you will log into azure and get
all signed up i'm actually going to show
the alternate route just in case you
have a problem with the browser so what
you can do is use a azlogin dash dash
use device code
so i'm going to ctrl c out of this and
again you don't have to do this if
everything worked fine i just wanted to
make sure that we cover all the avenues
here so az login
use device code just like so
and as you can see we've got a link
right here so i'm going to paste that
link in just like so and as you can see
i'm already logged into azure
and then
i just need to grab this code
and paste it in
there we go
and continue
alright it says we've signed in let's
verify there we go
and you can also validate by running az
account show
just like so
all right so now that we've done that
let's go ahead and add the terraform
extension
now you can use the official one but
honestly the official one has some
pretty terrible reviews so i've been
using this one here
let's go ahead and choose that extension
and install it but again you're more
than welcome to use any extension you'd
like here
and then what we need to do is open
a new folder where we'll store our files
so let's go ahead and file
open folder
and i'm just going to hop into my
documents
i'm going to create a new folder
and we'll just call that
terraform azure just like so
go ahead and open that select folder
and all set and once again i'll just
make sure that everything is set up for
azure
az account show
still logged in everything looks good to
go
first thing i'm going to do is just
create a new file and we're going to
call that
main.tf
just like so go ahead and open that
and now i'm just going to pull that out
of the way and let's take a look at the
azure docs now as you can see here we've
got our azure provider and what this
provider does is allows terraform to
communicate with the azure api that's
how terraform knows how to deploy
resources so as you can see if you look
down you'll see authenticating to azure
and the way we're doing it is with the
azure cli of course you can feel free to
read these other options here those may
work better for your organization but
for us the azure cli works perfectly
fine so this is our configuration that
we're going to use for the provider
here's some more stuff down here we'll
get into that very soon but we're going
to start here now as you can see we've
got terraform and then we've got
required providers so any of the
providers we're going to use are
specified in this block so we've got the
azure rm provider the source here is
hashicorp azure rm and then we've got a
version
now this is actually freezing this
version to 2.97.0
your version may be different and that's
perfectly fine of course if something
does break you can always revert to this
version and please let me know so that i
can update the course
now below that we then actually specify
the provider up here is indicating which
providers will be using within terraform
and then here is actually how we will do
the connection and specify any other
options that we may want to specify now
as you can see if you scroll down we've
got
all of these arguments and one of them
is features which is required
so even if we don't use anything within
the features block because it's required
we still need to include it as you can
see here it's included with an open set
of curly braces so basically it's an
empty map so
as you can see there are lots of other
options that you can use feel free to
peruse that
but let's go ahead and get coding
now you can just copy and paste that in
i'm just going to type it out
just to get a little practice going
so we're going to start with a terraform
block
open and close some braces
required
providers
open and close some braces again
azure rm is our provider
and then let's provide the source which
equals hashicorp
slash azure rm and then version equals
again in my case 2.91.0
now you don't necessarily need to
specify this but it's a good way to
ensure that the code always works so
after that we just provide that
configuration block provider
azure rm
and that open features block there
so this is all we need here and of
course you can provide more providers
you can even provide two azure providers
if you want you'll just need to name
them differently and that's how you can
potentially use different accounts or
different regions or something like that
but in this case we're going to keep it
simple so now that we've done that
let's go ahead and run a first we'll run
a terraform fmt
and that stands for terraform format and
as you can see that kind of cleaned up
our code a little bit removed some
indentations things like that so it's a
good habit to run terraform format
anytime you are working with any type of
files especially before you commit to
your repositories
all right so now that we've done that
let's go to the next step and that is a
terraform init
just like so
as you can see we're initializing the
back end and the back end is a local
back end which means that our
terraformed state where everything is
stored
will be stored here all right everything
is successfully initialized
let's take a look at what we've got
we've got the dot terraform directory
here this is actually where the provider
is stored and this is a compiled file so
this is actually a compiled go file
or in windows case an exe file as you
can see and that is what is used to
communicate with the api of azure and
then what we have is our terraform
lock.hcl
and as you can see this can constrain
the version that we use you typically
want to commit this to your repository
so even if this version isn't set
this lock.hcl will maintain that version
to ensure that your code always runs
now if you decide to upgrade that
provider
you may want to just delete this file or
modify the version so just keep that in
mind
now if you were paying attention you may
have noticed i accidentally left an s
off the end of features so i want to
illustrate a point here
terraform init is not interested in
anything else except for
provider related stuff so basically i
could put whatever i want to down here
and if i run a terraform init
it has no problems whatsoever
but if i change the provider and
accidentally use the wrong provider name
or a wrong resource name which we will
look into
it will fail
so do keep that in mind init is not
sufficient to test your code you will
need to run a plan which we will cover
soon
so to fix this provider let's go ahead
and make sure that's fixed and make sure
that feature is plural just like so
features
perfect so that should be good to go so
now let's take a look at the resource
group documentation
now as you can see we've got some notes
here none of these are going to affect
us but do be aware that whenever you see
notes in the documentation like this
it's probably a great idea to read them
as sometimes they will indicate some
very very big issues that you might
encounter and how to solve them so now
let's scroll down here we've got our
example usage as you can see we've got a
resource here so just like we have
provider here
this is a resource
and this resource is azure rm underscore
resource group
now this cannot change this indicates
the type of resource that you are
deploying
so you want to make sure you use the
right name for that resources terraform
will have no idea what you're trying to
deploy if you don't use the right name
now this
is an alias
the following here can be anything you
want for the most part
you have to adhere to some grammar rules
but for the most part it can be just
about anything you want
and this is how you will reference this
resource within terraform
now azure doesn't know anything about
this alias but terraform does this is
how it's stored in the state so after
that we've got our arguments we've got a
name and then this is azure specific
location azure specific
and then also we can pass in some tags
azure specific
and now once you create this you can
actually go into the state using several
different methods it will cover
and you can also attain the id of the
resource once it's deployed
there will be no id that you can find
until of course it is deployed within
azure so let's bring the code back over
here and let's go ahead and start coding
in fact what i'm going to do
scroll up let's just copy this block
right here
and we'll paste it in just to help
prevent any type of typos since i'm very
prone to those
so we've got a resource azure rm
resource group and let's just call that
mtc-rg
just like so now the name since this is
actually in azure we're going to make
that a little more specific in this case
we'll just call it
mtc-resources this is also to illustrate
that these can be different now the
location i'm going to use is going to be
east
u.s just like so
and then below that i'm going to specify
some tags
so tags equals
open and close some curly braces and
let's just give it an environment tag
so the environment equals depth we're
not really going to be doing much with
these tags in this course but of course
for billing purposes or any type of
other resource management it's nice to
know what environment your resources are
deployed to so now that we've done that
let's go ahead and control s
now let's run a terraform fmt once again
clean things up as you can see it kind
of pulled that environment back a little
bit
and then let's run a terraform plan just
like so
all right so that was a successful plan
and what this is doing is showing us
what is going to be built if we run a
terraform apply
so as you can see we've got our plus
signs for create there are other signs
but right now we're not changing
anything
so you can see that we're creating this
new resource and then under that you've
got the
argument so we're passing in and as you
can see we've got the id
known after apply which means we will
know that as soon as this is deployed to
azure
so let's go ahead and deploy that
let's go ahead and run a terraform apply
and hit enter
alright as you can see it ran a plan
again
and then it asks us if we would like to
perform these actions if we'd like to
continue
so yes we would definitely like to
continue now in the future we will use
the auto approve flag just to skip that
because we are running a plan between
all of this so we don't need to get
another confirmation
but generally speaking when running from
the cli in production it's probably a
good idea to have this extra step just
to ensure you don't make any mistakes
so we'll go ahead enter that yes and hit
enter
and give that a little bit of time and
it should be deployed here shortly
all right apply complete resources one
added zero changed zero destroyed
perfect let's go take a look in the
azure console
going to refresh here
just going to click up here to the left
and i'm going to click on resource
groups
all right and this first time i've
logged in this account so we've got a
lot of pop-ups here let's get rid of
those
as you can see sometimes resource groups
take a little bit of time to show up
but once i refresh here they are
mtc-resources
so we open it we can see all sorts of
other information about it so that is
excellent we're going to set the
groundwork for our deployment by
deploying a virtual network
in order to do that we'll also need to
learn how to reference attributes of
other resources so
let's get started alright so we've got
the documentation which is where we
always start right here now there are
some notes here and eventually these may
be deprecated but for right now they are
fairly important
some of the demos and examples are going
to show inline subnets we're actually
not going to do that we're going to
specify our subnet as a separate
resource that gives us more control over
the resource itself how it relates to
things its dependencies and lots of
other little benefits that you'll see as
you start to build your own larger
deployments so as you can see here this
note covers that standalone subnet
resource and some of the pitfalls so
let's scroll down to this example here
now we're not going to use a lot of this
as you know as i just mentioned the
subnets are in line so we're not going
to do that we're not going to worry
about the dns servers we're going to
keep it pretty simple with just name
resource group name location address
space and tags now one thing you can
take a look at here the resource group
name references the resource group
as you can see
azure rm resource group dot example dot
name
so it is a resource azure rm resource
group dot example
dot
name
so we've got the
resource type the resource alias that we
provided to it
and then one of the attributes
all using a dot syntax
and then the same is specified with
location
so let's go ahead and do this ourselves
so i'm going to roll this back over and
let's get to coding so we will specify a
resource just like so
once again in quotes for the resource
type azure rm
virtual network just like so
and i'm just going to give it an alias
of mtc mtc-vn
and then open and close our braces
then within here we need to specify a
name
and that we'll just call mtc network
again i'm being a little more detailed
with my name within the resource itself
but the alias doesn't need to be as long
so the name mtc network
then we provide the resource group
name just like so
so that's going to be azure rm
and we can actually take a shortcut i'm
just going to press down
and tab right there to tab complete that
so azure rm resource group just like
this azure rm resource group dot
mtc-rg
which is this here
dot name
now you could also just specify mtc
resources if you wanted to but you don't
want to define the same thing in
multiple places because if we were to
change mtc resources we'd have to change
it in every resource that references it
now another reason why it's important to
reference resources by their resource
address instead of by hard coding them
is because this creates an implicit
dependency
basically
now this network will not deploy
before this resource group has been
created
in the same whenever we destroy it will
not destroy this resource group until
this virtual network is destroyed so by
referencing this resource group from the
virtual network we tell terraform that
this virtual network is dependent on
this resource group so now let's specify
a location
and that's going to be very similar to
this so i'm actually just going to copy
this
paste it down here and add dot location
which again is defined here as east us
and then what we want to do is specify
the address space
also known as a cidr block
address space is and this is actually a
list you can specify
multiple address spaces here
but we're just going to use one we're
going to use 10.123.0.0
and if you're not familiar with subnets
i strongly recommend you review them
feel free to reach out if you'd like any
tips or where to start and then under
that let's add some tags i'm actually
going to give a little bit of space
between my details and the tags here and
once again environment equals
dev and you could copy and paste that
too if you want to
all right i think that's everything
let's go ahead and run our terraform
format and after that let's run our
terraform
plan
okay we're seeing a lot of green here
that is good we've got one resource to
add
looks like everything we specified as
you can see
we'll also have access to information
about the dns servers after apply the
guid the id
and the subnets here
but possibly
after you apply
so that's great let's go ahead and get
this network deployed so terraform apply
and as i said we're just going to use a
dash
auto approve here and if you want to see
everything else you can actually do a
dash help
and you can see lots of great options
here
but right now we're just going to focus
on applying
so terraform apply dash auto approve
feel free to pause the video while yours
is applying and then come on back
whenever it is finished
all right one added zero change zero
destroyed let's go take a look
here i am in my resources group here
i'm actually just going to go back to
home real quick
click over here to the left just so we
can see how to get to it the long way
i'm going to click on virtual networks
and there it is mtc dash network
everything looks like it's here we've
got our address space dns servers
location
everything looks great
so wonderful
we're going to take a slight detour from
building
to dive into probably one of the most
important terraform concepts the
terraform state so let's go ahead and
get stated i mean let's get started
alright so here we are as you can see
we've got all of our resources that
we've deployed so far and you may have
noticed this terraform dot state file in
this terraform dot tf state backup file
let's take a look in them and see what
we're looking at
so if you open it up and let me go ahead
and preface with under very very very
few circumstances should you ever modify
this state manually
there are specialized commands for
making state changes and things so for
the most part one you probably shouldn't
have direct access to it it should be
stored remotely
but two
don't go around and start changing
things in this state it's not the right
way to manage your resources with that
being said let's take a look as you can
see each state has a version
it specifies the terraform version it's
got a serial number a lineage a lot of
really good information to help you
understand which state you're dealing
with and every time the state is
modified it actually creates a backup as
you can see here it's got a serial of
one so once we run a terraform apply or
destroy again the terraform state will
be backed up with this terraform state
information and a new terraform.tf state
will be created so as you look through
our state here you can see a lot of very
familiar attributes right here we've got
our azure rm resource group
with a name
then you've got the provider there also
then under that we've got id
location name tags etc etc and as you
scroll down you'll see we also have our
virtual network here so that's pretty
cool and all of that of course is
exactly what was deployed within azure
so let's take a look at
a better way to see what we need to see
in our state
because again typically speaking you're
not going to store your state locally
you're going to send it off to some sort
of other storage some people with aws
store and s3 you can store it in
terraforms cloud you can store it in
services such as space lift and more so
let's go ahead i'm going to close this
file
let's bring this up just a little bit
and let's go ahead and run a terraform
state list
all right so that's an easy way to see
all of the resources we have and then if
we want more details about what's in
those resources we can run a terraform
state show
and then we just utilize one of these
resources so i can just copy this
paste it in and hit enter
and there we go so now we get the
information from that resource
and now if we want to see the entire
state we actually just run a terraform
show
so keep that in mind terraform show
will show you all of the state as you
can see here
and then terraform state show
is how you view specific resources
just like so
so if we take a look at the docs here
there's actually a good bit that you can
read through i strongly suggest you get
very very familiar with it we're
actually going to be going through a few
of the other features of the state
throughout the course but this was a
good quick run-through
of how to utilize a state and once again
we'll be checking in every so often to
make some modifications to that state
we're going to check out a command
almost as fun to use as terraform apply
but much more fun to say now that
command is terraform destroy now if we
take a look at the docs we can actually
see that a few things have changed since
terraform came out originally terraform
destroy was the proper way to do this
and it still works as you can see
terraform destroy followed by options
this is an alias for terraform apply
dash destroy now you can also run a
terraform plan dash destroy which of
course will not perform the destruction
it will just let you know what it's
going to do
so let's go ahead and take a look now of
course what terraform destroy does here
is destroy everything that you've
created but let's take a look at a few
things first first what i'm going to do
is just run a terraform state list let's
just take a look we have
two objects here as you know we've
deployed both of those
and then if i run a terraform
plan
dash destroy
as you can see we've got zero to add
zero to change and 2 to destroy
and if you scroll up you can see that
everything has this little red
dash next to it indicating that it's
going to be deleted
so if you ever see that red dash that
means that that resource is going to be
deleted all right so let's go ahead and
take a quick look let's look at our
terraform.tf state
just like so as you can see we've got a
serial of three here version of four
we've got a lineage and all this good
stuff let's take a look at the
tfstate.backup
serial is 1 there version is 4. let's
run this terraform destroy and see what
changes
so i'm going to run terraform apply dash
destroy or you can just run terraform
destroy if you'd like let's go ahead and
run that i'm going to pull this up a
little bit
alright and just like terraform apply
it's asking for a yes or no here you can
also use an auto approve so i'm just
going to type yes to destroy everything
all right all set as you can see it took
a while to delete that resource group
let's take a look at the tf state and tf
state backup again
here is the tf state as you can see
there is nothing in here anymore
and the serial has incremented to 6. now
if we take a look at the tf state dot
backup
here you go this was our old
tf state
so now if you ever needed to replace the
state or you made a big mistake or
something went wrong with the state
somehow the state got corrupted you have
this backup right here you can delete
this tf state and rename this one
to continue utilizing what you had
before
all right so that's all for this lesson
go ahead if you'd like and run that
terraform apply auto approve real quick
to put everything back to where it was
we're going to deploy a subnet into our
virtual network this way we have an ip
address space that can be used by our
virtual machines so
let's get started so as usual let's take
a peek at our azure rm subnet resource
here it's got a very similar note here
that we saw on our virtual network
resource that indicated that these
subnets can be deployed in line with the
virtual network but in our case and most
other cases it's better to deploy it
separately from the virtual network now
as you can see here it's actually
listing our resource group and virtual
network which we've already done
so all we need to do is deploy the azure
rm subnet just like this now as you can
see there are several arguments here
we're not going to use all of them and
if you continue scrolling you've got all
sorts of great little notes here most of
which do not pertain to us and this
deployment but again it's very important
to read those and understand what you
might need to know for future
deployments alright so now that we've
taken a look at that these are the
following attributes that will be
exported
id name resource group name name prefix
prefixes and again right now we don't
need most of that but some of this we're
going to be reaching out to later so
anyway let's get building
all right so back in the terminal we'll
start a new resource
and that's going to be an azure rm
subnet
just like so
and we'll just call that mtc dash subnet
keep it nice and simple and then the
name
we'll just call this mtc subnet
but i will say that in future
deployments you might want to add a one
or a random string to that but in this
case we're going to still keep it simple
and then resource group name is what we
need to supply second
and that's going to be our azure rm
resource group which i'm going to tab to
complete dot mtc-rg
dot name
just like so now after that we need to
provide a virtual network name
just like so
and that's going to be our virtual
network which is going to be azure rm
and if you just scroll down here you can
see the virtual network and of course
you can also see it and copy paste from
right here if you'd like
virtual network dot
mtc-v in
and we're going after the name here
which is mtc network as you can see
there and we're just going to use name
so this name here references the
mtc-network perfect and then after that
we need to provide the address prefixes
and that just like above is actually
going to be
in a list which means there are brackets
on the side and it can accept multiple
arguments now we're only going to use
one prefix here
but of course if you needed to provide
multiple you'd be able to
generally speaking if you see a plural
name here for the argument
that's expecting a list so you will be
using these brackets so that's going to
be
10.123 and we'll just use
dot 1.0
24 just like so all right so that's all
we've got to do for this subnet
let's go ahead and make sure that i
coded everything out right we'll run a
terraform fmt
which aligns some things for us and then
we're going to run a terraform plan
i'll drag this up some
all right one to add zero to change zero
to destroy it looks like everything we
asked for is there the id of course will
be known after apply just as it has been
before the name mtc subnet
resource group name mtc resources and
virtual network name mtc network as you
can see those were populated just fine
by referencing the name of these
resources
all right perfect
so go ahead and run a terraform apply
dash auto approve
all right apply complete everything is
looking good if we run a terraform state
list
we can see that our subnet
dot mtc subnet has now been deployed
and of course you can also go to your
azure portal
i'll go home
i'm going to click into my mtc resources
just like so
then we'll click on the network
and within here you can see subnets on
the left
and there is our mtc subnet
all right perfect we're going to add a
very important resource to our
deployment the security group
so
let's get started
first let's take a look at the docs over
here and as you can see we have another
note
now with the security group you can
actually define your security group
rules inline just like this
or as separate resources
now to keep things consistent we're
going to deploy our security group rule
as a separate resource
instead of adding it in line this will
make maintaining our security group
rules a lot easier and allow us to make
deploys and changes without any real
unexpected consequences if you scroll
down you can actually see a security
group rule can be configured both inline
and via the separate resource we have to
explicitly set it to an empty slice to
remove it honestly that's just a little
bit weird i don't like that i'd much
rather just remove the rule entirely as
a separate resource versus having to
manipulate our whole security group
so this is going to make things a lot
cleaner and easier to manage so let's go
ahead and get started with that
as you can see the security group is
actually pretty simple name location
resource group name
and some tags so let's go ahead and get
that done and then we will add the
separate rule so i'll bring the code
back over let's go ahead and get that
going
resource
azure
rm
network security group
mtc and we'll just go sg just like that
open and close our braces
name equals
mtcsg
location equals
azure rm
and we're going to be using the location
in our resource group
so i'll just select that
dot mtcrg.location
once again remember
in our resource group we have the
location right here
so we're just using azure rm resource
group mtc-rg
location to get our proper location and
after that
we've got a resource group name
and that's going to be azure rm
select that resource group there
dot mtcrg
dot name just like so and then after
that let's add a tag
tags equals
environment
need to spell that right environment
equals
dev all right perfect i'm going to ctrl
s to save that
and then let's go ahead and add our
resource group rule so i'll move this
code out of the way and i'm going to
select the
azure rm network security rule resource
and if you take a look azure rm network
security rule example you've got all of
these items here that need to be filled
in and then you reference the resource
group name and the network security
group name
so i'm going to cheat just a little bit
here and copy this so we're not typing
this whole thing i type fast but not
that fast
let's go ahead and bring it back over
let's paste that in
and now take a look at the things that
need to change
first using example is not very
descriptive
let's go ahead and call this mtc dash
dev dash rule basically indicating this
allows for developer access
and then the name i'm just going to call
mtc
dev rule just like so
priority at 100 is fine obviously if you
start adding more rules you might need
to change those priorities
all right and then of course direction
here we are not worried about outbound
outbound is going to work for us we need
to set inbound because right now we're
trying to allow access to our instances
and subnets not out from it access allow
now the protocol is currently tcp which
actually would work for most of our
cases i'm just going to go ahead and
replace that with an asterisk to allow
for icmp or anything else we need and
the same with source port range
destination port range
source address prefix
now this right now is allowing anyone
quite frankly i don't want anyone seeing
my ip address it doesn't change enough
for me to want to do that but i would
definitely recommend you add your ip
address here and to do that you can go
to any ip address finding website or
just check your router or whatever you
need to do to get your public ip address
then just add that here
and you would do it with this syntax
ending with a slash 32
but once again i'm going to leave this
as an asterisk and then as far as
resource group name
that would be mtc-rg
and network security group name
as you remember we made that up here
mtc dash sg
just like so
all right that was a lot of stuff there
let's go ahead and run a terraform fmt
let's run a terraform plan and see how
many typos i made
all right fantastic that's actually kind
of impressive everything looks like it's
ready to deploy we've got our security
group
and our security group rule
so let's go ahead and run a terraform
apply dash auto approve
all right everything applied
successfully we can run a terraform
state list
and we see all of our fun new resources
there everything is good to go we're
going to associate our brand new
security group with our subnet so it can
be actually used to protect it so let's
get started as you can see here we have
our azure rm subnet network security
group association quite a mouthful
luckily it's not that long of a resource
it's actually very very straightforward
and very simple so let's go ahead and
just knock that out i'm actually going
to copy right here from the docs of
course if you don't have the page open
feel free to just type it in or pull it
from the code downloaded from the
official repository of this course and i
am going to paste that in
so we have our resource azure rm subnet
network security group association
and we'll just call that something like
mtc dash sga nice and simple to say and
then here we have our azure rm subnet
and that was mtc
dash subnet
dot id
then here we need to specify our network
security group id and that was
mtc-sg
if i remember correctly let me scroll up
to verify
yes right here
mtc-sg
all right perfect and we are referencing
the ids of both as you can see id and id
and that is literally all we have to do
i know that is a relief coming from the
last few longer lessons
let's go ahead and run our terraform fmt
let's run a terraform plan
all right as you can see one to add
everything is looking good id known
after apply network security group id
which it found and subnet id which it
found and that will allow our network
security group to protect our subnet so
let's go ahead and run our terraform
apply
auto approve
all right everything applied
successfully we're going to give our
future virtual machine away to the
internet by creating a public ip
so
let's get started
alright so here we are with the azure rm
public ip
pretty straight forward we've got a name
a resource group name location
allocation method here you'll see static
we're going to be using dynamic and then
some tags
you scroll down you can see we've got a
lot of different options here
but the only one we're really concerned
with is the allocation method since
we're going to be using dynamic instead
of static all right feel free to peruse
those a little bit but let's go ahead
and get started with our coding so i'm
actually going to just copy this here
let's go ahead and
add that
just like so azure rm public ip in our
case we're going to name this
mtc-ip we'll keep it very simple
and then the name once again let's keep
it simple with mtc-ip
and i do want to call attention to this
again in the case of this deployment it
is a very very static deployment there's
not going to be a lot changing not going
to be a lot adding this is really just a
way for us to deploy a simple and quick
development environment so we're not
going to have multiple ips necessarily
or multiple security groups or whatever
now if you do anticipate adding things
you're going to want to make sure
you add either a number to this or some
other string or even use a random id
resource which terraform offers to
append some sort of random string to the
end of these so that if you do deploy
multiple you don't have overlaps so just
keep that in mind
but in our case we're going to keep it
simple then for the resource group name
let's go ahead and add our mtc-rg
like we have before
and of course the location
mtc-rg and we're going to change this
allocation method to dynamic just as we
saw and for tags let's go ahead and just
set it to dev
all right perfect i think that should be
everything let's go ahead and run our
terraform fmt
then let's run our terraform plan
all right everything looks good as you
can see we've got our dynamic there mtc
ip everything is looking correct as far
as i can tell
now one thing to note even though it
says there's an ip address known after
apply it will not be known after apply
this is kind of a strange thing about
the way azure works the public ip when
set as dynamic will not show up until
it's attached to something and used so
just keep that in mind
all right i'm going to run our terraform
apply
auto approve
all right apply complete perfect
go ahead and run our terraform state
list
and then what i'm going to do is grab
this ip right here and i'm going to copy
that ctrl c for me
let's run a terraform state show and
paste that in
there we go
and as you can see
we do not have an ip address here
but once we deploy our other resources
we will be able to extract that ip
address and use it in the future
we're going to create the network
interface that we will attach to our
virtual machine in order to provide
network connectivity
this nic will receive its public ip
address from the ip address we just
created so
let's get started alright so here is our
network interface if we scroll down we
can see it right here and as you can see
it kind of gets our usual suspects the
name location resource group name we
then get the ip configuration under that
and we've got a name for that
subnet id
and private ip address allocation but as
you can see we don't have public idp
address listed here which is something
that is very important to us so if you
scroll down
you can actually see a public
ipaddress.id
right here so we're going to add that
and reference our public ip with that
attribute so let's go ahead and get
started
all right we're going to type this one
out again just to give us a little more
practice typing this
we'll use a resource
azure rm underscore network underscore
interface
and let's go ahead and call that mtc
nick just like so
then under that
let's give it that name
and that's just going to be mtc nick
location
equals azure rm we're starting to get a
lot of resources here as you can see but
let's scroll down and find that resource
group and tab that in dot mtc dash rg
dot
location just like so
then under that we've got our resource
group name
and that's going to be azure rm
once again resource group
dot name
all right and now we need to provide
that ip
configuration block so ip underscore
configuration
open and close those braces
name and we'll just call that internal
just like the docs say
subnet id
equals
azure rm
subnet
dot mtc-subnet
dot id
under that we then provide our private
ip address
allocation and that's going to be
dynamic we're not really worried about
it in this case what the private ip
address is that our instance gets
and then we provide the public ip
address id
and that is azure rm
public ip.mtc-ip
dot id
and then let's add a tag down here for
good measure
tags equals
environment equals dev
just like that
all right everything is looking good at
first glance let's run a terraform fmt
everything's good so far let's run that
terraform plan
all right as you can see on the resource
group i actually left out
a very important part of that
dot
mtc-rg dot name
as you can see it gave me the line
number and everything pretty easy to
find where the error was and how to
troubleshoot it all right so let's run
that terraform plan again
excellent everything is looking good
we've got a lot of green plus signs here
these network interface cards are a
little bit complicated
but that all looks great so let's go
ahead and run a terraform apply
auto approve
apply complete resources one added zero
changed zero destroyed
so if we run a terraform state list
we've got our nick there
and if we run a terraform state show
add that to the end
as you can see we have a private ip
address right there but i'm not seeing a
public ip address yet
let's go ahead run a terraform state
list once again
let's grab that mtcip public ip
run another terraform state show
add that
and still no ip address we're going to
create an ssh key pair this will be used
by the linux vm resource we created so
that we can ssh into it later so let's
get started all right as you can
remember from the docs we've got the
admin ssh key right here
so that's all we have to do we just have
to create the key first
so let's head back into our
terminal actually
let's go ahead and run an ssh keygen
dash t
rsa we're going to create an rsa key
pair all right and i want to save this
users
derrick
dot ssh and again this is windows which
is why this might look a little bit
different but you'll want to just save
it in the same path that's illustrated
here we're just going to rename it
so slash i'll just name mine mtc as your
key just like so not going to bother
with the passphrase there
and we're all set so if i run in ls home
slash dot ssh
you can see my mtc azure key and mtc
azure key dot pub
are there ready to go
perfect
so go ahead and clear my screen there
and then what i want to do is add that
key pair and i'm actually going to put
that above this os disk just to keep it
consistent with the documentation but it
really doesn't matter as long as it's
within the mtc vm block
so admin ssh key
username equals admin user as we
remembered before
and public key equals and now we're
going to use a terraform function so
just like any other programming
construct it basically is the name of
the function
followed by parentheses so we're going
to use the file function and what the
file function does is reads a file and
substitutes its contents for the value
here so what we'll use is we'll use
our mtc as your key dot pub since it
wants the public key right here and
we're going to read that using the file
function make sure you wrap that in
quotes
so file is going to pull the contents
out of this mtc azure key dot pub
and insert those into this argument here
so it's going to fill this out for us
now if you want to check out the docs
you can check them out here pretty
straightforward as you can see you
basically just pass the path into the
file function
and there are also some other functions
file base 64 which we may look into very
soon file exists and template file
all right so now that we have done that
we now have a way into our instance so
now let's go ahead and apply and make
sure that we can log into our instance
so i'm going to run my terraform
format once again to clean all of that
up
and i'm going to run terraform plan
let's make sure everything is looking
good
all right beautiful as you can see one
to add everything is looking good as you
can see here the file function did
exactly what it was supposed to do and
added this here doc syntax to the
beginning and end of it
so that is great everything is looking
good so let's go ahead and run a
terraform apply
auto approve
all right all set everything applied
correctly which is just wonderful
so now let's go and see if we can find
that ip address let's just run once
again a terraform state list
and we've got our brand new virtual
machine right here go ahead and copy
that
and then terraform state show and paste
that in
and if we scroll up here we can see
we've got our public ip address for our
instance right here
perfect go ahead and copy that
let's clear the screen and then let's
ssh dash i
pass in that mtc azure key that we had
admin user was the username we specified
at and paste that ip address in
alright you may have had a confirmation
screen go ahead and click yes if you did
otherwise here we are all logged in
and if i run in lsb underscore release
dash a
we can see we are now within our ubuntu
instance
all right perfect so i'm going to exit
out of that
we're going to utilize the custom data
argument to bootstrap our instance and
install the docker engine this will
allow us to have a linux vm instance
deployed with docker ready to go for all
of our development needs so
let's get started alright first of all
what i want to do is create a new file
and we're just going to call that
customdata.tpl
now tpl is the extension we typically
use for template files we're not going
to make this necessarily a template file
but just for consistency's sake we're
going to use that here just in case
you'd like to eventually add some
variables
but for right now
let's go ahead and paste in the code
provided in the lesson should be a bash
script
just like so and what this is going to
do is install all of the dependencies
necessary to install docker on our
machine so go ahead and save that and
feel free to close that tab and then
what i want to do is add the custom data
argument and i'm just going to go ahead
and put that up here near the top
so custom data equals now remember how i
said we'd be using the
filebase64 function soon well this is
where we're going to use it
as you can see the filebase64 function
is very much like the file function
but what it does is it encodes it in
base64 which is what the custom data
field for azure is expecting
so let's go ahead and
filebase 64. open and close some
pairings
and we're going to pass in
customdata.tpl
just like so
and of course if this was not in this
directory you would specify the
directory where it could be found but
since it's in this directory we don't
need to specify any slashes or anything
like that all right perfect
so that's actually all we've got to do
there as far as coding goes let's go
ahead and run our terraform fmt
and then let's run a terraform plan
all right perfect now we've got
something a little bit different this
time around we've got one to add zero to
change one to destroy
so this isn't changed because custom
data requires the vm to be redeployed
for it to be read so it's going to
destroy
our instance and replace it with a new
one as you can see here custom data
forces replacement
now another cool thing you can see is
sensitive value certain arguments can be
dedicated as sensitive and custom data
is one of those this way it does not
show up here
now it can still show up in your state
and that data of course is still in this
file
but it's not going to show up right here
for everyone to see in your terminal
alright so perfect this is exactly what
we want let's go ahead and run a
terraform apply
auto approve just like so
all right apply complete as you saw
there was a pretty long destruction
process
but everything looks to be up let's go
ahead and see if we can log in now
so we're going to need to get that ip
address again so let's run our terraform
state list
and we'll just grab that virtual machine
right there
and terraform state show paste that in
i'll scroll up a bit and there it is a
brand new fresh ip address
so let's go
ahead and i just ran a control r there
and i'm going to start typing ssh that
saves me a lot of typing right there if
you press ctrl r and search for that ssh
command that should help you out
otherwise feel free to type it out
manually again
paste in that new ip address and type
yes
all right we are in our brand new vm
let's see what happens let's go ahead
and run a docker dash dash version bam
perfect so now we have docker installed
on our brand new vm
ready to go we're going to install the
remote ssh extension in vs code which
will allow vs code to open a remote
terminal in our vm
and then we're going to take a look at
the configuration scripts we're going to
use to insert the vm host information
such as the ip address into our ssh
config file that vs code uses to connect
to those instances so
let's get started
so first up i'm going to click on
extensions here
and i'm going to type remote ssh
just like so and i'm going to click
install
all right that is all installed for me
perfect
so then let's take a quick look at it
let's open the command palette and as
you can see mine's already there but you
can also start typing remote ssh
and just to see how things work
if you click on add new ssh host and
let's just say ssh
admin
at
admin.com or whatever
let's go ahead and hit enter
you can see you've actually got options
potentially to configure different files
go ahead and click on this first one we
want this location to be within our ssh
directory so click on that
and if you open the config
you can see i've actually got a lot here
you can see the format we're looking at
we're looking at a host hostname user
and identity file just like so
so what we're going to want to do is
extract that information from our
instance and insert it into this
configuration file
so let's take a look at how our script
is going to do that
let's go ahead and create a new file
and depending on which operating system
you're using let's go ahead and create
the file necessary
so since i'm on windows i will use
windows dash ssh dash script dot tpl
just like so
and within that file i'm going to copy
in
the script you can find in the course
resources
so what this is going to do is add the
host hostname user and identity file to
that file that we specified
now as you can see you've got this
interpolation syntax here and what this
is doing is essentially dictating that
these are variables
and those variables will be passed in
using the template file function which
we're going to cover very very soon so
go ahead and save that
and then i'm also going to create the
linux one so you can see that
so linux dash ssh
script
and of course this also works for mac as
well
so the linux script is just like this
you're basically cutting in
the same type of stuff to
our ssh config location all right so
perfect so now we see exactly what's
going to be used to add the information
to that script we've seen the script and
we've installed our ssh extension so
coming up we're going to start prepping
our code to add this information so that
we can connect to our host using vs code
we're going to utilize a provisioner to
configure the vs code on our local
terminal to be able to ssh into our
remote vm now a provisioner is not
something you want to use for every
deployment unlike other resources a
provisioner's success or failure will
not be recorded or managed by state so
if something goes wrong that's just too
bad there is no rollback or any other
way to manage it other than just running
it again while this is not great for
configuring remote instances it's
perfectly fine for something like this
just adding information to a config file
on our local terminal this is a
lightweight operation that doesn't
affect the overall success of the
deployment if something were to go wrong
so generally speaking if you need
something simple to do use a provisioner
if you are configuring a remote instance
it's usually best to either use user
data custom data or another type of
application such as ansible but anyway
let's get started so let's take a look
over here first up we've got our
provisioners and as you can see here as
i was hinting at provisioners are a last
resort
now if you scroll down
you can see there's a lot of stuff that
you can do other than provisioners and
one of those is what we did custom data
but if you keep scrolling down there's
actually a lot of great information
about using provisioners
and one of the most important things
here is the usage of self within a
provisioner you can just specify self
and that will extract whatever
attribute you need
from what you're deploying so if you
need a private ip or a public ip
you just specify self which simplifies
the code
and then of course you've also got
creation time provisioners which is the
default and then you've got destroy time
provisioners as well
destroy time provisioners will perform
an action whenever you destroy the
script so just keep that in mind
definitely read over this as
provisioners can be very useful as long
as you use them sparingly and with
caution so let's go ahead and set up
that provisioner now that provisioner is
going to be set up within
the azure rm linux virtual machine block
so let's just head down here above the
tags i just like having the tags last
for some reason
you specify provisioner and then you
need to specify the type of provisioner
and you have local exec and remote exec
again remote exec i would use very
sparingly better to use user data or to
use ansible or some other better tool
but this is a local exact provisioner
which means it'll be running locally
and again
lightweight doesn't cause any disaster
if something goes wrong with this
provisioner so then what we need to do
is provide a command
so let's go ahead and provide that
command that command is actually going
to be one of these scripts and to
specify one of these scripts and pass in
the variables we're going to use what's
called a template file function
so if you check out the template file
function here
you specify template file just like you
did the file function pass in the path
to the file
and then you pass in the variables
so there's a lot of good stuff here that
kind of dives into that
let's go ahead and see how that's going
to look for our deployment
so we're going to use the template file
function
just like so
and then we need to pass in for me the
windows dash ssh dash script dot tpl and
then i need to pass in the variables
and that's going to be in a block of
curly braces so what we want to pass in
is the hostname
and that's going to be self
dot public underscore ip underscore
address which is how you access the
public ip address of this instance
within state so we take a look at the
terraform tf state and as you can see
here public underscore ip underscore
address
so that's what we want so self.public
underscore ip underscore address is
going to give us that
and then the user is going to be admin
user just like so in quotes we then need
to pass in our identity file
and that is going to be located in that
home directory ssh
slash in my case mtc as your key
and of course that is our private key so
do keep that in mind and then after that
what we need to do
is specify an interpreter
so what the interpreter is doing is
basically dictating whether we're using
powershell or bash or whatever shell
we're using to run this script and in
our case we're using powershell if
you're using windows
so for me it will be powershell
and then comma
dash command
all in quotes
now if you're using linux or a mac
your interpreter will be
bash
comma
dash c
just like so so this is your interpreter
if you were using linux or mac
but i'm going to delete that from mine
all right that should be everything let
me take a look at my script here
host name user identity file
hostname user identity file all have
been
defined so everything looks good there
so now let's see if this works so what i
want to do and remember everything right
now has been deployed if you want the
same result i get which is going to hit
a little snag
go ahead and deploy before you do this
otherwise just watch and you'll see how
i handle it all right and before we go
further as you can see i've actually
made a couple of typos unfortunately
this keyboard seems to be failing on me
so i've gone ahead and corrected those
let's go ahead and run a terraform plan
and see if i missed anything else
all right so here is the snag i
anticipated as you can see
no changes but we made a pretty big
change that's a lot of typing in our
resource here
a provisioner does not get picked up by
the state remember
so it doesn't know that anything has
changed
so what we need to do is we need to
get rid of this instance we need to
destroy it
and reapply it and there are a lot of
ways to do that but the best way to do
it is just to replace it this used to be
called tainting a resource and i guess
hashicorp didn't like that word so
they've changed it to the replace flag
so let's go ahead and utilize that
so first terraform state list
let's go ahead and copy our
vm right there
and then run a terraform apply
dash replace
and then paste in that resource
all right so as you can see using that
replace flag replaces our virtual
machine
which will then run our provisioner so
let's go ahead and say yes to this
all right so we have an apply complete
let's go ahead and see if this worked so
i'm going to head up to view
command palette
and i'm going to select remote ssh
connect to host of course if you don't
have that go ahead and start typing
remote ssh
and if we scroll down here
20.121.205.65 let's see if that is it
so i clicked on it we're going to select
linux
i would like to continue this is a very
good sign
all right we're logged into something
mtc vm now i've only spun up one vm so
this has got to be it let's docker
version
does not appear to have been installed
yet so we'll give it a little bit of
time and then we will see
all right it took a little bit of time
but guess what
docker is now installed everything is
working perfectly and we now have an
awesome little remote terminal directly
to our instance so we can start
developing and we're going to take a
look at terraform data sources now data
sources are ways that we can query items
from the provider in this case azure api
and utilize it within our code
although we don't really need it since
it's already available in our state file
we're going to query the public ip we're
using just to illustrate how data
sources work so let's get started so if
you take a look we've got the data
source documentation
not too incredibly complicated basically
we just specified data instead of
resource we then pass in the data source
we want to use
give it a name and then pass in any of
the expected arguments
and if you scroll down you'll see there
are several different types but we're
going to keep it very very simple
so what we want here
is we want the public ips available to
us to be released so we want to be able
to see these and access them from within
our state and eventually pipe those to
an output
so let's go ahead real quick and see how
this works so here i am back in my
console i've actually closed out of the
one connected to my instance and let's
go ahead and add this data source here
down at the bottom
so we're just going to specify data
azure rm underscore public underscore ip
mtc
ipdata is what we'll call it that sounds
good open and close some braces
then the name equals azure rm
underscore public underscore
ip.mtc-ip.name
so what we're doing is we are querying
the ip address we created up here
as you remember the name mtcip
we are querying that to get its ip
address
now once again we don't really need to
do that because we're using the same
state file we just access it however we
want or just access it just using
our resource names
but if you for instance had another
terraform deployment without access to
that state then this is a way that we
could do it we could actually use a data
source to access that ip within azure
without having to dig through the state
file
so after that it just wants a resource
group name
and of course that's going to be azure
rm underscore resource underscore group
dot mtc dash
rg.name
just as we've used many times before so
what this is going to do is find the ip
address that matches these conditions so
now let's go ahead and see what this
looks like in our state and what i'm
going to do we actually don't need to
apply again
because this data source is not a
resource it doesn't need to be applied
all we need to do is a refresh so we're
still going to use the apply keyword but
we're not going to actually apply
anything to azure at all
so we'll run terraform apply dash
refresh only
and as you can see there are no changes
but we know we have made a change at
least to our configuration file
so we do want to apply
apply complete let's now take a look in
our state
open that state up you can see we
actually have our new data source here
if you scroll down we've got the ip
right there right at the top very easy
to find so if i run a terraform state
list
as you can see we now have our
data.azurermpublicip.mtc.org
which reflects this so once we need to
access that we can access it using that
alright so that's all for this lesson go
ahead and mark it complete come on back
to the next one and let's continue the
course
we're going to add a nice little
convenience feature to our script by
utilizing outputs to display information
that we need as you well know we've been
manually finding the public i p address
of our instance to verify it well that
is incredibly inefficient so let's add
an output to make that a lot easier so
as you can see here in the docs we have
output values and basically all we need
to do is
say output give that output a name
and then specify a value it's pretty
straight forward now keep in mind
outputs are only rendered when terraform
applies the plan
so just running a plan is not going to
work we do need to apply it so let's go
ahead and take a look at this
alright so what i want is just an output
to get our ip address and instead of
referencing the instance i'm going to
reference that nice little data source
we created to keep things very simple so
output and we'll just call that public
underscore ip underscore address just
like so
open and close those braces
and then we need to give that a value
now what i'm going to do is use
interpolation syntax and we're actually
going to take a look at a couple
different little features here so first
up all of this will be in quotes and
what i want is i want the name of our
mtc vm so if that is mtcvm i want
mtc-vm
colon ip address whatever that might be
so to get that
what we're going to do is use
interpolation syntax once again it's a
dollar sign in these curly braces which
allows us to utilize variables and
reserved keywords within a quoted string
so what we're going to use is azure
rm
underscore linux
virtual machine go ahead and tab through
that dot mtc dash vm dot name just like
so so that's going to give us our name
now after that we're going to add a
colon
and a space
and since those are outside of the
interpolation syntax as you can see they
are
brown on my screen which means they are
part of the string so once we've done
that of course we could just use the
same exact string
dot public ip address but we're going to
use our data source as i said
so for that we'll use data
dot azure rm
underscore public ip
dot
mtc ip
dash data
dot
ip underscore address
all right and as you can see if i run a
terraform state
show
and just pass this in this first part
you can see ipaddress is the attribute
that we want all right so let's go ahead
and run our terraform
apply dash refresh only and let's see
what happens here
all right as you can see there have been
changes to outputs
and here's what we're going to get
absolutely we would love to do that so
yes
apply complete
so now what i can do is just run
terraform output
that gives us all of our outputs if
there are multiple you can also ask for
that output specifically
just like so
all right
perfect so now every time we apply we're
going to get our mtc vm or the name of
the vm that we've got colon ip address
we're going to start optimizing our
script and making it more dynamic by
adding variables so
let's get started
now so far we have been hard coding
everything as you know our windows ssh
script that is hard coded in and then
we've also got our interpreter here now
one thing that might change a lot as we
move from station to station computer to
computer starbucks to starbucks is that
we may be changing different operating
systems so it would be a lot nicer if we
could dynamically choose which operating
system to use based on which terminal
we're using so let's go ahead and take a
look at that as you know we've got
windows ssh script and linux ssh script
and then we've also got the windows
interpreter and the linux interpreter so
let's go ahead and change this and what
i'm going to do is use
interpolation again
and we're going to add var dot host
underscore os right here
so now what's going to happen is this is
going to insert the value of whatever
this variable is once we set it so let's
do that
and now let's go and define this
variable for us
so now we could just add a variable
right here in the same file but let's go
ahead and split off the variables file
so we're going to create a new file
called variables.tf
just like so
and any tf file is going to be
considered by terraform on any apply as
long as they're in the same directory so
i could have 27 different tf files are a
tf file for every single resource output
and everything else i want in their own
separate files and terraform would
consider them all the same deployment so
we've got our variables.tf here let's go
ahead and create
that variable so variable
host underscore os just like so
let's open and close some braces there
and then we just need to provide a type
now this is not required but it's very
friendly to your coworkers
this way they know what type of variable
they need to specify so that could be a
map a string a number just any other
type that terraform recognizes you can
specify here to help guide your
co-workers to understand what variables
should be set
let's go ahead and save this we have our
variable declaration here it is
initialized but it's not defined
and then let's go ahead and run a
terraform destroy
so terraform destroy dash auto approve
and as you can see it's asking me for
that variable now
so any type of terraform destroy plan or
apply anything that modifies the state
is going to ask for that variable if it
is not defined anywhere and we will look
at more of that in the coming lessons
so let's go ahead and since i'm on a
windows machine i'm just going to say
windows
and hit enter
and everything was destroyed
successfully
so now let's just run a terraform plan
just to show and it asks once again
for the variable we've now seen how to
initialize a variable and how to define
it at the command line but as we saw
that is not a great way to define
variables when in automation as it
requires dynamic input which is the
opposite of automated so in this lesson
we're going to look at a few other ways
to define variables and which of those
ways take precedence over the others so
let's get started alright so the first
thing i'm going to do is head into my
variables.tf and we're going to add a
default value
now go ahead and add that default to
whatever operating system you're using
i'm going to use windows and anytime i
say windows you can use linux and
anytime i say linux you can use windows
just to stay consistent so i'm going to
go ahead and save that so right now that
means that it will always use windows or
at least fall back to windows
so what i'm going to do because it's
actually a little bit quicker is i'm
just going to use terraform console
and then what i'm going to do is type
var
dot host underscore os
all right and as you can see terraform
console is a very handy tool that allows
you to access anything within the state
that you need so now i'm going to exit
out of that
going to head back to my variables.tf
and let's remove that default
and run
terraform console
var.host os
and as you can see it says known after
apply and that's because you will need
to specify that variable when you apply
terraform console isn't going to ask you
so now what we want to do we want to
define that another way let's go and add
another file
called terraform
dot tf vars
now what this is is a way to define our
variables and it's also generally
considered to be a sensitive file you
usually will not send this to your
repository but there are several cases
where you will so just keep that in mind
so within this we can just define the
host os equals
windows just like so
so now if i run terraform console
and run var.host os
it's defined once again
perfect so as you see terraform.tfvrs is
another way to define our variables so
now i'm going to exit out of there again
clear that
now let's take a look at another way to
define our variables if we run a
terraform console dash var equals host
underscore os equals linux
let's see what happens
var.host underscore os
is now linux so if the variable is
defined on the command line and you can
use this dash var
with terraform plan or terraform apply
or even terraform destroy then it will
override whatever is set on terraform
dot tf vars
and terraform.tf vars will override
what's set within variables.tf
as the default so let's go ahead and see
another example real quick
let's create another file
and i'm just going to call that let's
just say os x dot
tf vars
and even though that isn't one of our
host os's let's go ahead and do that
anyway so we're going to say host
underscore os equals
os x just like so and save that
and then let's run
terraform console
dash var dash file
equals
os x dot tf vars
var.host underscore os is now os x
so as you can see we can utilize the var
file argument here
to override
terraform.tf
vars which then overrides variables.tf
with the default setting all right so
that is everything we now have a general
idea of how variable precedence works
within terraform and different ways to
specify those variables so now that
we've managed to choose our ssh config
file dynamically based on the definition
of our host os we now need to make our
interpreter dynamic unfortunately this
isn't as easy as interpolation syntax
replacement so we need to look at a
better way in this lesson we're going to
utilize conditional expressions to
choose the interpreter we need
dynamically based on the definition of
the host os variable so let's get
started so as you know now we are able
to specify our host os
as a variable which will then replace
this
and allow us to dynamically choose the
ssh script that we use now we haven't
applied this yet but this works so now
let's see how to specify the interpreter
appropriately
which again our other interpreter which
you may have if you're on mac os or
linux and that's bash comma
dash c just like so
so if we're on windows we need to use
this one and if we're on linux or mac os
we need to use this one here so let's
see how we can do that so we take a look
in the docs
you can see essentially what we want is
a condition
question mark true value or false value
it's essentially a ternary expression so
if we specify a variable we then decide
based on what that variable's definition
is whether it's going to be
one item or a different item
and the second one is going to be the
default so let's just take a look at
this in the console
and by console i mean terraform console
this is going to be a lot easier than
trying to dig through and explain by
dragging the mouse around on some
documentation so let's just say
var.host underscore os
equals two equal signs there
windows which it does for me and of
course if you're on mac os or linux use
linux there
we use our question mark
we're going to say powershell
or bash just like so let's go ahead and
hit enter
alright since our host os is set to
windows it's reporting powershell so now
let's see what happens if we need to
choose between these two so all we need
to do is var.host underscore os
equals windows choose between
power shell
command just like so
or
bash
dash c
and if we hit enter
as you can see it reports powershell
dash command
now if you wanted to invert that
you could actually do a var.host
os
if it does not equal windows
then return bash
or return powershell
so as you can see this is how you can
invert that but we don't need to invert
it we're actually going to use this one
right here so go ahead and
copy that because we're going to need it
very soon
let's head up to our interpreter and
let's actually paste that in now
just like so
all right let's save that let's exit out
of here
and then let's run our terraform plan
and remember in my
terraform.tfrs i had my host os defined
there as windows
all right so everything is looking
pretty good so far
so let's go ahead and run our terraform
apply auto approve
and let's make sure we get a new ip
address and a
machine to which we can log in
all right all applied as you can see the
public ip address actually did not get
populated by the time this was done
i'm imagining that is some sort of a
glitch here because it worked earlier
we've got our host ip address that
actually shows up in our local exec
provisioner here
so as you can see everything looks like
it went well except for that one output
so let's go ahead we can see this here
this ip let's run up to view and command
palette
ssh connect to host scroll down to the
bottom and well that worked perfectly
fine we've got our ip address there
let's log into it
that is a linux machine
continue
all right and we are in
so as usual let's see if docker version
is good to go yet
docker is installed it went a lot faster
this time so that is awesome we can then
open a folder if we'd like we can open
our home directory
just like so trust folder and continue
run a terminal and now we have a full vs
code environment within
our brand new virtual machine
so that is awesome
let me just go ahead and move that out
of the way let's take a look here
and now that some time has passed let's
run terraform apply refresh only and
let's see if we can get that output to
work remember this is a data source
and what that means is that it is
reaching to the azure api and there's a
good chance that that ip address just
wasn't quite available within the api
yet so let's go ahead and run terraform
apply refresh only
and this is a great way to troubleshoot
things like this because this type of
stuff happens all the time
bam look at that so it looks like we are
going to have an ip address after we
have this refresh finished
so we're going to choose yes
and now it works so if i type terraform
output
we've got our ip address and then back
over here we also have
our terminal ready to go
so now you have a reproducible
development environment within azure
that you can deploy anytime you want use
for whatever you need commit to a code
repository or whatever and destroy it
alright so go ahead and you can close
that and if you are finished run a
terraform destroy
auto approve
and that's everything i hope you enjoyed
the course feel free to reach out to me
for any questions you may have and don't
forget to terraform apply yourself